surprise surprise julian edelman of the
patriots set to join us here
mercedes-benz brought to you by Mercedes
AMG e-class be prepared for whatever
comes your way the all-new GT 4-door
coupe because life's a race visit your
local dealership test drive today Julian
Edelman joining us how do you feel today
I feel pretty good I feel not too bad
you catch a second wind when you hit the
playoff so it's with the adrenaline rush
in that uh you know you usually be
pretty sore but now you you're already
thinking about what you got to do to get
ready for next week so doing alright
what was your expectation I'm good I'm
good I'm not sore at all I didn't get
hit at all over the weekend what was
your expectations going into that game
what did you think was going to happen
huh I really didn't think about what was
going to happen I was more thinking
about what we had to do to just execute
our plays you know I was just trying to
a little coaching points that were
coached out and and little details of
each intricacy I was just trying to
literally study for an exam for that and
you know that's keeps my mind a good
place and then you go out and you play
the game do you have a test like you
would said you're studying for a test
but is there a quiz where you're asked
about certain things in certain
situations you know we're always
definitely quizzed here and there a
little bit there but there's no actual
braking but uh you know you I feel like
the test is you know when you walk
through you have a walkthrough with with
the whole you know with your whoever
you're with and you want to go out and
try to do everything that you're coach
that week and that little walkthrough
just to kind of you know night before
you can sleep just kind of keep the the
confidence going and that's that's kind
of my test mentally fit up
do you care about the weather did you
care if it was snowing raining cold um
not necessarily I mean we practice in it
and of course you always wanted a little
warmer it's when it's cold it's cold but
you know we we practice and outdoors
always coach keeps us in that mindset of
you know whatever hangs outside
put your crap on go out and practice in
it and that's you know we remind that
you don't really think about that I was
shocked at Brady talking trash
you know bulletin board material here
Julian I'm gonna guess Kansas City is
going to be playing this up Seaton would
you play Tom after the game pretty
strong stuff here from Brady it's a
rematch against Kansas City this time
though in Arrowhead what can we expect
from that one no good games are a good
team and we played a murder this year
you know I know you know everyone thinks
we suck and you know can't win any game
so we'll see it'll be fun
yeah that's it I mean that's some pretty
heavy bulletin board material by Brady
he never says anything you know the fact
that we'll see you know that's that's
about as strong as brick you know behind
the scenes I'm sure Brady's gonna say
hey these bleep and bleep errs there you
know we're underdogs going in there so
I'm sure it's different when he's made
his boys we are the two seed so you know
hey we're uh we don't underestimate any
opponent and that's how it is here so I
can't speak for Tom but I you know just
you know I'm hey it's gonna be the
toughest game of the year and we we have
to prepare for that because I mean was
it to see we're going on the road and
and that's just how it's gonna be so you
know we will see and I wish to shoot out
the last time you guys faced one another
it's just weird how it just feels like
these games come down to a defensive
stop or can you make a defensive stop so
we've seen wide-open offenses this year
but
playoff football is just different yeah
I mean little colder you're a little
more online so yeah I don't know it goes
either way I've been in a lot of playoff
games and you know I've been in this way
that way this way you can never really
predict so you know you don't even think
about trying to predict because it takes
away from your time where you could be
thinking about what you have to do to go
out and do your job when's the last time
Brady yelled at you probably probably
like last week on this little subset I
mean it's kind of like kind of like a
married couple I don't get yelled at as
much but I get I get a look like come on
come on babe are you allowed to yell at
him I do sometimes you know is I I feel
I don't know I probably shouldn't but
yeah but he put me in my place
hey congrats safe travels to Kansas City
good to talk to you again Julian thanks
for joining us I write and I heard are
you still working on that shot oh it no
it's it goes in it never wet yeah it's
really wet it's really wet I remember
watching the show yeah I don't hear
about this god I want to see it I don't
miss I don't miss I haven't missed since
last time I talked to you I got to see
it I got to see it to believe it but I'm
called don't believe the hype now I'm
the Tom Brady of jump shooters so Julian
Edelman yeah come on in come on the man
cave see firsthand they all doubt if you
missed any of our interviews
mercedes-amg man cave you can go to Dan
Patrick app where you can watch and
listen from inside the mercedes-amg
kay mercedes-amg driving performance for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]